we're asked to identify which expression
is larger five squared plus three to the
fifth or three to the fifth and then
that whole thing squared so let's just
let's just work this out so let's do the
first one here five squared plus three
to the fifth five squared plus 3 to the
not 35 plus three to the fifth so what
is 5 squared 5 squared 5 squared is the
same thing as 5 times 5 which is equal
to 25 so that right there is 25 and
what's 3 to the fifth well 3 to the
fifth 3 to the fifth is equal to 3 times
3 times 3 times 3 times 3 and what's
this going to be 3 times 3 is 9 9 times
3 is 27 27 times 3 is 81 and 81 times 3
is 243 it's 243 so this up here is the
same thing as 25 this is equal to is
equal to 25 that's what 5 squared is
plus 243 plus 243 which is equal to what
we can do this in our head 268 right 268
right 268 so that's what this first
expression is now let's see what 3 to
the fifth squared is so 3 to the fifth
squared this one right here so it's 3 to
the fifth squared well we already
figured out what 3 to the fifth is 3 to
the fifth is 3 times 3 times 3 times 43
it's 243 so this right here this
expression right here is 243 and we're
gonna square that entire thing so this
is equal to 243 squared now they just
want to know which expression is larger
and we already have a pretty good sense
the first expression is only 268 the
second expression it's the numbers a
little bit smaller than 268 but it's
that number squared this is 243 times
243 which you might already sense is
going to be a
much larger number than 268 so you
should at this point already say hey
this is a much larger number than that
we don't know the exact number yet
but this you know if they just want to
know which expression is larger it's
definitely going to be this one and if
you're just out of curiosity you want to
know what that number is we can we can
solve it so if we do 243 times 243 3
times 3 is 9 3 times 4 is 12 3 times 2
is 6 plus 1 is 7
put a 0 down here 4 times 3 is 12 we're
just in a different color so don't get
confused
4 times 3 4 times 3 is 12 4 times 4 is
16 plus 1 is 17 put a 1 here 4 times 2
is 8 plus 1 is 9 now let's do this last
row over here do we have the twos put
two zeros here 2 times 3 is 6 2 times 4
is 8 2 times 2 is 4 so let's add
everything up and what do we get we get
9 just a 9 there 2 plus 2 is 4 7 plus 7
is 14 plus 6 is 20 2 plus 9 is 11 plus 8
is 19 19 1 plus 4 is 5 so you get 59,000
49 which is clearly way bigger than 268
this expression right here is 59
thousand and 49